Okay. Do I have tips or advice for data scientists?
>> To become a data scientist.
>> Yeah, for aspiring data scientists. That's a
great question and I think going back to the
issue of what is data science. Like I said,
I think there's really I would, I would divide
it into 3 somewhat different parts. And, and so
one of the first pieces of advice that I
would give to people looking to get in the
field is to think about what you really like,
what, what part of this kind of work do you
really enjoy. I think for some people it really is
the process of building things, of writing code, of building
a product that let's say you know, surfaces recommendations or finds,
you know similarities between users of a product. So you
know, if you really like that, that sort of aspect
of building things there's a lot you can do in
that direction particularly around improving
your coding skills, things like that.
If you really enjoy the analysis part, the statistical and
mathematical side of things, there's a lot more you can
do there in terms of coming up to speed with
new machine learning techniques, learning statistics more in depth. And then
finally, on the communications and strategies side there obviously a
lot that you can do to improve your communication still, skills.
Understand how to abstract from the details, how to abstract
out the high level issues that are important to a company.
So the first piece of advice I would really give anyone looking to move into
this field, is to understand which of those 3 areas you enjoy the most or what
the right mix is for you. And make sure you're focusing on the skills that, that
will help you get ahead in the particular
direction that's of the best fit for you.